[Music]
the next 60 minutes will be about
serverless data-processing give you a
bit of an overview of what we'll be
reviewing today or looking at they
they'll quickly go over some of the
technical benefits of cloud dataflow
this is a level three hundred sessions
session so we'll skip most of the basic
stuff and just provide some of you but
dive deep into the technical benefits
pretty quickly I will do a demo of a new
feature that we have to launch just last
month dataflow templates it will show
you how easy it is to do data processing
without operating any servers and
launching pipelines without any servers
of them deep dive into two particular
benefits of cloud dataflow specifically
dynamic load balancing and auto scaling
I'll do a demo of auto scale and show
you the history of auto scaling for
particular type line that I will launch
alcohol anchor to stage and here it is
going to talk about a breitkopf is using
cloud dataflow and several other DCP
products so to provide video analytics
to their customers we'll have a recap
and to also do a Q&A if you would like
to ask questions we have two microphones
in the aisles so at the Q&A session just
come up and feel free to ask so most of
the customers before they start using
cloud dataflow they use something that
is called
a lambda architecture a collection of
tools a doob sparks kafka which is
optimized to for specific flows of data
for batch processing and for steaming
processing once once our customers are
switching to data flow they take
advantage of a unified one this is one
of the major reasons why customers are
migrating to cloud dataflow it offers a
unified way of doing batch and streaming
and you can use it in conjunction with
other GCP system product
such as pub/sub and bigquery to build
your data processing pipeline if you're
a fan of open source computing and who
isn't you can also use cloud dataflow
with with another stack of data
processing applications we have open
sourced our SDK and became Apache bean
which just recently became a top-level
Apache project and you can use theme
runners on a variety of in a variety of
environments including spark Flegg and
some others to summarize why customers
are using cloud dataflow by the way just
by by the show of hands who has already
been able to run a few dataflow pipeline
ok a good good idea sort of the audience
so cloud dataflow first unified way of
doing batch and streaming you get access
to a fully managed environment you can
spend your time on optimizing your
pipeline code instead of running and
managing server infrastructure we offer
you a open source project model so you
are not locked into just one vendor you
can run beam pipelines in cloud dataflow
or you can run and run it in on-premises
or other cloud providers with other
runners such as parties links and we
also able to to scale from maybe a 10
records per second incoming data stream
to millions of Records per second
architectural a he's a architectural
overview of cloud dataflow we are a
black box that connects sources and
things we support streaming and batch
sources we call them bounded unbounded
sources and we write into variety of
things to offer connectors for sources
and things then we also offer a bunch of
benefits under the hood
including we create the worker BMS for
you which actually executes and run your
code we optimize the pipeline's that you
submit to us you you can keep kind of
thinking
at the more abstract level and I say if
you are a sequel program or think about
analyzing a simple query and then
submitting into a database that we do
the optimizations for you
we skill resources for you up and down
depending on the workload and we do a
redistribution of work between workers
when particular workers become what I'm
going to talk about two specific
benefits later in my presentation but
that was going to pay overview of all
the benefits that be the pro provides if
you are a developer then from a
developer's point of view you write
pipeline code we support multiple
languages Java and Python this code has
access to a wide variety of data
transformation function in our SDK the
buguese a language in the temple so they
offer the same functionality in both
Java and Python
we call it the beam model beam provides
abstraction to example if you want to do
parallel to process data elements in
parallel you can use a transform called
Pardo because I do we transform for
parallel processing if you want to group
things by key in any language Java or
Python you use a goodbye key transform
and as already mentioned once you go to
pipeline and kind of chose your your
language your SDK you can run it in a
variety of runners you can run it in
cloud dataflow et marinatin spark and
you can run it in flag so I wanted to
highlight four specific technical
benefits of cloud dataflow before I do
my first demo I will mention the the
full management extract aspects of cloud
dataflow we create workers for you we
allocate the split your data inputs into
smaller shards and allocate them to
workers go to do optimizations of your
execution code example you might start
with a pipeline and pipelines can be
thought of activity diagrams where you
have
bubbles of transformations and data
flowing from one transformation bubble
to the next transformation bubble so you
think in terms of these activity
diagrams and what you want to do with
data you define your transforms and you
connect them you submit your pipeline
graph to us and we optimize the
execution sometimes you don't know ROG
steps together if you think that it will
be more efficient to do both
transformations together sometimes we
split them up to achieve a higher level
of parallelism yet another benefit of
cloud dataflow is auto scaling so think
about a workload which maybe starts with
just 800 records per second incoming
data stream the beginning of the day
your users are not doing much to just in
generating about eight thousand records
kiseki duality just a sufficient number
of workers which which are required to
process this incoming work see now
during the day your users who begin
submitting more events it might've
reached several thousand five thousand
from this example throughout of scaling
cloud dataflow is able to stamp the
increase in CPU utilization DN T's in
incoming data rates and increase the
number of workers
automatically to a much higher number
not only do we increase the number of
workers we also decrease them when the
workload is about when your incoming
data stream is declining and lastly the
last feature I wanted to highlight and
these are the two features out of
scaling the dynamic load balancing which
I wanted to kind of give dives audit
later it's important that I covered them
on a higher level source in Stanek work
rebalancing I already mentioned that
when you have tell us your data inputs
and let us allocate the workers to
process the data input some of the data
charts which we create be the shards of
your input data might might contain data
which takes longer to process than all
the other sharks
we call side shards stragglers and
sometimes well actually quite often
because of the existence of stragglers
your entire data pipeline will take
longer to execute because we are waiting
for the completion of the of the
struggle with the feature that we have
dynamic worker balance is actually able
to steal tickly work from the worker
which is struggling and he allocated to
other workers now I'll show it in a demo
which I want to do just now and you
switch to the demo machine first in the
demo I'm going to start with showing you
how easy it is to to start a dataflow
pipeline we have recently launched a
feature called dataflow templates
templates allow you to write your
pipeline deposited into a GCS bucket and
then call on this code whenever you
would like and wherever you would like
you can initiate the template from the
console you can initiate the sample into
a dataflow job from Q cloud or through
the API in my demo I'm going to use a
export of a publicly available data set
of packages those of you who know me
know that I am really excited about text
analytics I love natural language
processing I write algorithms for
crunching through through from news
articles trying to extract opinions from
text so I took the I took one of the
public datasets that we have how can use
news post and dump them into a bunch of
CSV files for this demo
as you can see in the ccs pocket where I
dumped my parking use dataset I have
about 30-40 CSV files of the size of
about 125 megabytes but one particular
file is extra long and you'll see why
it's important this file and a delight
file CSV is 5.5 Giga bytes long and
those are the stragglers I'm talking
about
sometimes you did is just larger the
data shards are larger than other
datasets so let me start my data flow
pipeline
I'm going to go to the data flow console
and click on run job and this new UI
you're able to choose which template you
would like to instant read some of the
options are I can do a custom template
custom template is the code that you
write and place in GCS and you can then
share it with others and span sheet it
into digital jobs etc I don't actually
use a simple algorithm that we typically
do for typically share with customers
when they start learning about data flow
it's the Ward County algorithm it's
quite simple it reads from text files
counts the number of words and then the
statistics on on these from these words
I'll give the job a name demo job or one
and specify my input
GCS bucket
I'll use a pattern to catch all the CSV
files in this bucket and lastly I will
also specify my output bucket where the
attack statistic should eventually end
up that's all I needed to do to launch a
data processing pipeline I didn't have
to install any ideas I didn't have to
launch any VMs I can basically launch
now pipelines through the console using
the Stamper Cheng mechanism and within
seconds data flow will start showing you
the execution steps of this pipeline as
I mentioned before it's a little bit
simple it reads lines from my input
files
it runs the tax calculation algorithms
it does some mapping work and then
applies into GTS files I will come back
to this pipeline in about 10 minutes
and to show you a couple of other things
that I will continue talking about
during my presentation slides so this is
the code of the pipeline reading from
files applying a data transform to
calculate statistics on tags in parallel
form at the output and writing back into
files because cloud dataflow is a
parallel data processing service we
offer you as the user the ability to run
your transformations data
transformations in parallel and we call
these capabilities purdue's so basically
define a transform function we call them
do functions do fonts and then you tell
the depart do transform to go and
execute your do function the do function
takes data in a certain shape and this
diagram is represented by yellow yellow
breaks a yellow
squares and appreciates them into data
elements of a different shape maybe adds
additional fields removes them
aggregates them again in the diagram
represented as green star since all data
flow is a parallel data processing
service
we're on many many workers that do that
execute your transforms the best way of
visualizing what your workers are doing
your worker virtual machines are doing
is to display a Gantt chart in my
diagram here I have eight workers
working on data charts leaders are some
is my input data set that I subdivided
into smaller chunks so these eight
workers take a data shard they work on
it they complete it and they start
working on the next data set is a
real-life Gantt chart of a dataflow
pipeline of four hundred workers running
for about twenty minutes during three
texts it reads files it then does a
goodbye key operation and this is why
you see this way clean separation
between stages first needs to leave the
files once it has entire data set it
begins grouping data by by T's and it
also writes into files with parallel
data processing one of the big problems
that I mentioned before is the the
presence of stragglers and struggle
thoroughly your data charge which take
longer to execute than the average
execution time for all the other data
files of your data set and this diagram
here drivers would be the bar in red and
the yellow one is kind of approaching
the Ducato
we're just travelers come from and this
is important because if we want to
provide you a service which does
minimize these three sources that we
that we utilize the tech improves the
execution performance of your data
pipelines we need to be able to detect
strugglers and we need to be able to
deal with them so the first step here is
to understand where they could come from
they could be coming from from a uneven
distribution of your input data for
example if if you if your input datasets
are textual files
let's pick your favorite language let's
say English English has a natural skewed
data distribution to to the frequency of
water starting with a particular letter
so all the all the data charts which
contain words starting with the teeth
example will be longer than your other
data chart where else to data such a
strugglers come from well example if you
do a joint operation and you have to
have two input datasets and you're
trying to join each key on the left-hand
side which with the corresponding key is
on the right-hand side but some of the
keys on the left I'm using the
left-right technology in joints but some
of the keys on the left you will have
many more records on the right and this
is again another reason where you could
have struggles not only does the data or
your data could could complete two
strugglers you can sometimes also have
issues where the infrastructure and you
can have issues with networking or
perhaps a slow disk something something
is going on with vos or DBM restore
there are not enough resources on a
particular virtual machine that runs
your code to to process data quickly yet
another reason for data struggles what
could you do taught us about this issue
well you could start splitting your
input data into yet
high number of chars that might help in
some cases you can try to let your users
you being the the bender of a data
processing service you could let your
users define business rules and try to
kind of find you how many workers are
allocated to be charged which of the
workers are being allocated to the
charge and so on not so the complex but
can be done you could collect statistics
on data before the execution of the
pipeline and and create and start you
your
strugglers course to example so that
they can complete faster on the hardware
side or the infrastructure side this is
especially something that focus on the
Hadoop world or you could do backups and
restart which help with with this
problem well at fault data flow we spend
a lot of time thinking about these
problems and we deal with them by first
detecting struggles and fighting
fighting meaning dealing with with with
this problem so the first step is to
identify stragglers so what do we do
the for each of the shards and each of
the workers which process these shards
we always track the estimated completion
time we always estimate how long it will
take to finish the processing of an
active trial and when we when we hear
that the expected completion time exceed
the the average completion time for all
the other shards there is a flag this is
the indicator for us this shard will
become a struggler and will slow down
the pipeline so what do we do we split
them up clicking up means we up the
worker which is responsible for
processing these stragglers to give back
some of the work that there is wantable
for the given bags could consist from
give me a range of line items in your
input data set
give me a particular IDs and you input
data set that you are unable to process
quickly so that I can reallocate it to
other water so we continuously do that
and in my diagram here the green bars
represent work that is already completed
I have eight workers the voyage done
nine shards the fourth workers did all
digital the yellow bars represent shards
they're currently actively working on
and the these bars represent the
estimated completion time and for each
of these shards is calculated estimated
completion time and we detected for two
of them that they will delete and so we
will try to allocate work will not try
to reallocate the work will take away
more from these shards and reassign it
to other workers not only do it what do
we do it once during the execution of
the pipeline we do this repeatedly and
here's what it actually leads to going
back to my example of a real live
pipeline it's actually an example I
haven't shown here the pipeline is a
relatively simple transformation there's
only one type of transformation on your
data and a trance on 24 workers I'm
talking about the diagram in the upper
left quadrant here so 25 workers trying
to do a very simple transformation which
is simple pardhu but there's a skewed
data distribution and two of these
charge will take much longer than the
rest without load rebalancing the
execution of this pipeline will take
nine minutes but look what load
rebalancing gets to to the pipeline it
used the execution time almost fifty
percent to about four four minutes and
twenty seconds and look how how much
more utilized
the waters are now be complete and
approximately at the same time it's
another example of a pipeline that I've
mentioned previously 400 workers doing
somewhat more involved transformations a
read Purdue the region from files doing
a group by key writing to files the data
is not a problem it is uniformly
distributed but the still a bit of a
flag between some of the workers in the
region part and some of the variation in
the waters in the writing part with
without load rebalancing the pipeline
takes 20 minutes web load rebalancing
the savings are not huge but they are
nice 25 percent utilization is
significantly higher and we've reduced
all the slack all the white space
between the waters dynamic
load-balancing is trade in isolation but
it especially is useful when you start
thinking about adjusting the workload to
the variations in the incoming data
stream what we call Auto scale think
about the case where you you start with
three workers that's my diagram up in
the first row here so three workers
working on thermal data charge and for
the first couple of minutes since we're
doing the estimation of the completion
time everything looks fine it looks like
we can process the data within 10
minutes not a big deal but as time
progresses and as data flow is
consistently and continuously
reactivating the completion time we
learn more about the input data set we
begin something that the actual
completion will be much longer the first
couple of records in our data shards we
are our typical and the average record
you know data shard will cause the
pipeline to take readings great so we
realize you could definitely use some
some additional help why don't we start
a hundred new workers and transfer the
data just by throwing more CPU on it
well we could but if you don't have the
ability to divide the work of a life
running pipeline your additional workers
will be idle there will be nothing for
them to do without this ability to
dynamically be assigned work and
rebalance work auto-scaling just doesn't
work here's the diagram here's a here's
a screenshot of another real live
pipeline which starts with three workers
and kind of keeps learning about the
properties of your input data and
realises yes we can process we can
process the pipeline faster if we added
more workers and it's great that we have
the ability to divide the work so we
launch new workers we allocate work to
them every worker is working hard
there's no white space they are fully
utilized eventually a pipeline reaches
thousands of workers it crunches through
the data and completes and then skills
down shuts down let me show you how
exactly auto scaling is benefiting you
on the example of my pipeline that I
just recently launched demo machine
all right so here's my pipeline back to
my pipeline it completed with then
within about eight minutes reason why I
know it's completed is the green check
boxes in each of the transformation
steps for those of you who haven't seen
the beautiful console before and one
interesting feature that we have in the
Google console a Google developer
console is the history of auto scaling
decisions to check it out when you go
back the unseen appeared here's the full
history of what went on in your pipeline
lead lead from the bottom read from the
bottomless screen we started with a pool
of a single worker and remember I had
about 40 files in my input data set of
proximately the same size with only
exception of one file which was 50 times
longer 50 times larger than all the
other files so we data flow kept the
estimating and reallocating waters we
increase the number of workers to 2 then
8 to 15 and 15 seemed to be a be a kind
of a a good balance of nob of workers
and available data inputs so we kept
working at that level until we process
all the records and then shut down
hopefully that's this was a useful
demonstration of the capabilities of
dynamic load rebalancing and auto
scaling and with this I would like to
invite Ankara to Han from Brightcove to
talk about hi how bright Bob is using
data flow advice can we go back to the
slides
thanks sugar hello everyone I am there
we go hello everyone I'm uncle Johan
from bright coughs I am a software
engineer with the video analytics team
Brightcove is an online video platform
which provides video so end to end video
services to companies large and small
they're supposed to be snapchat order
but kept on disappearing after 10
seconds so we provide video analytics to
companies big and small which means that
we handle lots of data we deliver about
8500 years of video every month which
generates about 7 billion events a day
which generates a lot of time series but
because we believe that raw data just
crunched up together and summed up is
not useful we aggregate it down to about
80 million unique time series and this
all this is maintained by a pretty small
team of engineers about five or six of
us so basically half of the team is here
so as Sergey pointed out we follow the
pretty traditional approach we went with
a lambda model so as you can see the top
part is optimized for streaming
calculation whereas the lower part is
more of a batch system events come in
through the top from our web players and
Roku devices and Android devices and
iPhones and they come to our beacon over
HTTP GET aggregated in real time and
stored away into the real time database
at the same time we write all of this
down into logs and store and store it to
s3 so that we can allocate it every few
hours because one of the deal which you
make with the lambda model is that
aiming system is really optimized for
well being real-time that means that it
is lossy so to take care of that we have
a reconcile database which goes in every
few hours and happily Jones through all
the logs and gives it to a reconciled
database and the API comes along for
every API request and says it give me
the data for this this request that the
user is trying to make merges the two
data sets and gives it to the user on
the side we have a redshift database and
over that we have some BI tools written
so if anyone knows the work that goes
into managing a lambda model system and
everything they would know that it's a
little latent hadoop takes a lot of time
to churn through data you don't
absolutely get all your results
immediately plus there are more or less
two code bases here so you know every so
often we would get a support ticket
which says hey my results from yesterday
doesn't match the results from today oh
why is this ever so slightly different
so there's always been for that so all
all this is working fine and many years
it did and then you know things happen
you know most important one is
Brightcove is a growing company and more
people come online and they watch more
video which means that we have more
scale and we adding more disks we are
adding more compute nodes to a dupe
cluster which is now bursting out it
seems so we are spending more and more
time just keeping the lights on
essentially which means that lesser and
lesser features get delivered so we have
to do something about that but even more
important is that there were some new
features in line specifically session
correlation we
we thought was really important session
collation basically means that we had to
look at a viewing session in its
entirety it's a much more resource
intensive thing to do and the Hadoop and
the homegrown streaming system was just
not cutting it it was a lot of work and
we wanted to get something better at the
same time we wanted to use a more
performant execution engine which could
support all this and the future things
that we want to do as well as a more
robust and performant database layer
which could take care of all this so we
went you know we did did our research
and we found that everyone seemed to
recommend these slew of technologies
step pretty amazing technologies they're
open source so you can actually see the
source of the product and you can figure
out whether they actually wrote the
tests that they did the their
performance they have big communities
behind them so you know that you know if
you get stuck you will have someone to
don't do and hopefully they will be able
to answer your questions
so kafka spark cassandra hadoo mesa was
all good and we were like yay let's do
this sit down so we started plotting and
within the first 15 minutes of planning
you know beep-beep-beep pages going off
in our heads this is a lot of systems to
manage and with five people you would
essentially be just managing these
systems and we had to first of all
become experts at these systems to run
them establish them build monitoring
resources for them so dashboards and
alerts and then each of these systems
have like you know 500 variables do-kyun
just right to get in working in the
right way we want them
so it's not easy so we were like okay
you need to step back look at this again
so the basic theory in this architecture
is very sound you have a simple thing
that you are trying to do Event
collector goes to a message queue which
goes to some computation thing and gets
written to a database and we want to
write it to a warehouse and finally
serve it out but each of these
components are very heavy so we wanted
to sort of make them lighter and what we
wanted to do was look for some managed
solutions for this for each part of the
system so that with the five person team
we actually managed less and do more so
looked around and lots of claims lots of
marketing materials but if you're an
engineer you thought one thing for sure
trust but where if I never trust a
marketing material or a blogpost just
because it says 100% managed and
performant so we went out we wrote lots
of performance tests we did our due
diligence in making sure that we could
swap every component individually
without sort of getting locked into the
wrong thing and we went step by step to
make sure that we got it right so easy
pass easy parts first
we saw Google and we saw Google
container engine best way to deploy
application so we went with it we
deployed our micro services for the API
on top of GK straightforward we knew how
to do it run some there are lots of
resources to help us out and it's
kubernetes so even more community so
that that was perfect next we went with
how to deal with Kafka Kafka has this
magical dependency called - zookeeper
which
if you have managed it it it's just
completely magical in terms of just
going down for no apparent reason so we
didn't want to deal with it and what we
found that pub/sub was a very good
replacement for it
it is a globally available and durable
message queue which means that all the
work that we would have to do in terms
of keeping replicas alive and making
sure the cast car is properly provision
for our scale and is all good we don't
have to do so three months saved message
do you duplication by ID so you can
fiddle with the pub/sub and data flow
working together you can actually
deliver messages again and again and
assign them a unique ID and data flow
we'll make sure that it processes that
message just once so exactly once and
finally it because it's globally
available very little chance that you
get disconnected from every single
region of Google everywhere in the world
oh pretty much not going to happen so
okay next thing that we looked at was
our database it's the single most pain
point
operational burden of of our team like
we have spent weeks sometimes just
bringing the system up so we wanted to
find a solution to it our dataset is
time series based so BigTable Cassandra
was our first choice and then we looked
around and we saw BigTable was there and
if you read the Cassandra Doc's one of
the inspiration for Cassandra is the
BigTable paper so you're like okay
Google knows what it's doing it's a
pretty well respected paper so let's
check it out we wrote our performance
test and it just blew past everything
that we thought
in addition to that it's one button
scale up and down so you go into the
console you've set the number of nodes
to 30 and save and it's done and it
provides an interface using the good old
HBase API so there's lots of tooling for
it and it works very well very reliable
and performant so database another one
it's the easy button and finally ad hoc
analysis and doing bi of things at our
scale we get terabytes of data every day
so sooner or later a support call will
come in which says hey can you find this
absurd thing from your data set and we
wanted to answer that question and in
the past whenever we had to do that it
was a couple of days of going to s3 and
downloading a whole bunch of logs
running it through grep or some other
tool that we wrote and giving the answer
in if you have used big queries you'll
know how easy it is to actually run
queries and edits a console you write
the sequel query and it's done it's
almost as cheap as just storing files in
s3 and it's completely managed and it
churns through terabytes in seconds so
Emma date went for us things that used
to take days for us to debug and
diagnose took maybe five minutes at best
okay
elephant in the room spark and Hadoop
it's it's a monster system because it's
trying to solve a monster problem but
it's something that we wanted to tackle
so we again looked around and just at
this time Google dataflow had come out
of beta so so I come into beta so we
looked at it we read the paper that was
published we read some blog posts
we read some docs and we liked every
single thing it was right there and we
trusted none of it
followed by we went in and we you know
wrote a proof of concept over a over a
hackathon and two days later we were
like 50% of our feature set was
implemented in it which was great so so
we sort of sat down and looked at it
even more it for the first time I think
it provides a unified batch and
streaming model the B model is very
powerful so you don't have to maintain -
I didn't almost identical date code
bases just to do the same thing which is
a big win streaming reconciliation which
means that whenever pub whenever a
message gets picked up off pub sub you
know that it's going to get written it's
guaranteed to get done and you don't
have to do anything of of the sort of
retries and all those things and finally
its batteries included what I mean by
that is it comes with a slew of inputs
and outputs sources and syncs so you
don't have to implement them there's
like text input which Sergei used
there's pub sub and on the output side
we use big table but there's big query
text output many others and lots of
windowing operators so we want to do
session correlation we have to
essentially say window by session and
done so immediate win for us and we were
already one year ahead and off in our
game of implementing all this stuff
which is great so putting it back into
our original architecture diagram
everything inside the dotted box over
there is a managed service what that
means is that we would never get a page
for those services which also means that
someone in Google who is very well
trained for that job knows how to
diagnose debug and fix
services when they do go wrong and it's
a much linear system which means that
when things are not working or when we
want to develop something we know
exactly where to point that you know
what to tweet we know how to reason
about it which makes everyone's life
easier so what what did this give us
lesser pain more features faster and if
you look on the side we now have another
box which is bi tools and ad hoc
analysis so we got more stuff done
because we were able to get access to
tools which had much lower marginal cost
this there's no thinking around this
query is going to take eight days to run
so let me not do it you just go in run
the bigquery query get your answer get
on with life all of this took about six
months to sort of perfect and get it
right there were lots of lessons learn
and if if some of you have managed
Hadoop a lot of that knowledge transfers
over specifically if you want to speed
up your data flow or your processing the
best way to do is process less data
reduce your i/o use a better disk mainly
our SSD disk they're much faster you'll
get a performance boost like without
doing anything secondly is use a schema
schema data interchange format protobufs
is a great one we started with JSON JSON
is great when you're just starting out
it lets you we can twiddle with stuff
but it's not optimized for machines that
means a lot of your computers just spend
serializing deserializing and - in
addition to that you would spend a lot
of time just cleaning up the data so
you'll write tons of code just to make
sure that the right fields are present
the right format is there or something
or the other and the same
so we use protobuf and we like it and it
provides many many features some of them
being it's efficient and
backwards-compatibility finally being
from an analytics background I can I
cannot stress this enough monitor
everything what makes sense for our
workload CPU and observe that logs may
not make sense for yours you might have
a completely different set of metrics
which makes sense to you
so monitor them we make lots of
dashboards so that we have visibility
into everything and that worked out very
well for us
and finally when all fails you get stuck
there's a data flow team which was very
eager to help us out in in on every turn
so we really liked the team and then
before I go into a short little demo
this is a future roadmap which I would
not be showing over here at all have we
been implementing all this stuff using
spark and Hadoop adaptive aggregates we
analyze our customers requests volume
and their requests patterns and
automatically adjust how we aggregate
our data so that their queries magically
become faster lot more BI tools we have
started to build a lot more bi tools on
top of bigquery which give us which
gives our internal customers much more
visibility into data which just wasn't
there
and finally and it's a big one that we
were able to unify our analytics and
billing pipelines because there is a
hard guarantee that your data once it's
acknowledged actually gets saved to our
database we can be sure that it's good
enough good enough that that data exists
so the billing system can trust this
data analytics system always our
previous analytics system always
this thing that the billing data was
ever so slightly different so you trust
the billing and there would be questions
about it like why is it slightly
different and we would have to explain
no longer so that's great everyone's
happy everyone joyous so with that i'll
show you what our pipeline actually
looks like this is okay I'm going to
cheat a little bit because demo gods are
never create during demos so this is a
video of the same Google Cloud console
of our production pipeline as you can
see we are reading from two pub
subtopics at the top performing a bunch
of computations on them and churning
through data constantly and then finally
writing it back to do BigTable the
amazing thing here for me is that it's a
very simple representation of a complex
piece of software
each box directly lines up with a piece
of code that we have written so even
though data flow underneath the covers
is performing all these optimizations of
you know all different sorts of
optimizations we don't have to do those
not amazing and we can just concentrate
on how things look like so that was how
a pipeline looks like and next we have
maybe next we have the monitoring
dashboard so a mean intuition behind
making this dashboard is keeping it
simple so that when you wake up at 3:00
a.m. because of a page first of all the
black color does not hurt your eyes the
second part is that everything is
is exactly what you what you need and so
the first row is pub/sub metrics for us
pub/sub bat log is a good indicator of
how we are doing so when you know
there's a sudden increase in message
messages published to us and data flow
starts falling behind and it doesn't
keep up for some thresholds so let's say
three hours we get a alert saying that
hey go look at pub/sub or go look at the
data flow it's not keeping up we come
here and we see that okay message volume
increased pub/sub is backed up because
data flow is churning through it it'll
be good just leave it if it's if it's
Auto scaled it will scale up process
everything scale down everyone fine the
CPU utilization we monitor that just to
make sure that we know that we are
spending the exact right amount of money
we want to keep these machines as
utilized as possible but not so much
that they are over overwhelmed and low
CPU is generally a good indicator that
you know the pipeline just seized up for
some reason need some more work so to
the point monitor monitoring that helps
you go back to sleep and with that I
will hand the mic back to
[Applause]
thanks anchor let's recap we took a look
at how easy it is to launch data for
pipelines using beautiful templates we
deep dive into two specific technical
benefits of cloud dataflow dynamic load
rebalancing and auto scaling and we also
heard from breitkopf how easy it was to
build a video analytics solution using
data file
[Music]
you